hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play afraid of monsters I got one
that wants to mess with me ah how did I
do it cuz how did seven shots not kill
you [ __ ] these [ __ ] okay there we go
I don't get it I don't get it I don't
get it
ah one this guy I saw that doing this
guy off [ __ ] hell there's no way I
just got to get past him there's gonna
cost me some health no matter what I do
[ __ ] hell
[ __ ] you all all of you god damn it you
gotta be joking me ah
how the [ __ ] am I gonna get past him I
can't dodge them cuz they come in at
random points they just hit all over the
place and [ __ ] see I'm gone [ __ ] hell
evil ways 46 health how the hell am I
supposed to get passes I've got no ammo
and I've got no other defensive
abilities god oh boy this is gonna be
trial and error luck it's all know that
was extra unlucky because I [ __ ] screw
this grew this I hate those guys hate
him hate him hate him hate him hate him
screw you [ __ ] [ __ ] I can't believe
it you know before I stood still and
just did fine and now
oh wait save that 46 outfit here shirred
damn well better give me three give me
three give me through okay I'll take
that I will take that
oh you [ __ ] one throw the worst at
me
oh man okay I'll take that all right
reload give me some bullets reload oh
goodness
okay follow the red oh not this again oh
no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh ha ha
climbing on the ceiling I have it on the
ceiling huh oh
Oh
ah oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] you ah [ __ ] you no
no get some suck it down [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] that
oh [ __ ] you [ __ ] you just die just die
see you next week nice
you want some you're dead you're dead
you're fast you're fast
aren't you not you no no aah no not one
of those guys
ah [ __ ] hell oh [ __ ] hell why why
why would you do that to me
oh why would you do that to me why would
you do that to me
why Oh screw you
grave Oh like this oh it's not fair not
fair it's not fair
jump on your head maybe what the hell
waste all that ammo are you joking me Oh
screw this okay whatever
come here take your lumps oh you got oh
fine I'll wait come on die who's next
or I'm dead that's as fine - is gonna be
the bane of my existence I can tell
what's already okay shoot you you go
down you go down
oh come on why don't they die I screwed
I'm going pistol first more precise
anyway okay I gotta wait and then now I
can choose or you cannot die that's
huh yeah why get away get away get away
no no no no are yes or yes maybe I could
just get it down to one and then that
will allow me to kite it around and the
other big ones won't spawn or they'll
they will spawn probably and it's dodged
a moot point come on you die you die
[ __ ] hell
oh why they gotta be so fast
oh this [ __ ] you get five bullets to
that one okay that one's down this one's
down two down get down
yes okay I'm just gonna cut this one
around see if that does it nope they're
gonna spawn they're gonna spawn no
matter what and I'm just gonna be
dancing Oh gate please please gate
please please please gate please please
no no I'll just [ __ ] kill this one
and dance and dodge and hope to Jebus
that i make it hope that I make it but
no not gonna make it maybe I'll just
stand in one side and try to kill you
want on the other that way I can try to
avoid the damage I don't know but
there's gonna be two cuz that that's
fair because that is fair fair if I've
ever seen fair okay just go in a circle
that worked for for a little bit nope
not gonna work oh my god this is the
most unbalanced thing I've ever seen
it's horrifying is horrifying indeed and
be very horrifying it's just that there
ends up being so many bees in the air
there's nothing I could do my best
attempt was my first try
yeah just bear to mercy kill me then oh
man he's [ __ ] straight
shut up [ __ ] nothing I could do
nothing I could do maybe I got a
coordinating if I shoot - I strafe one
side and then the other I can kind of
keep them wah ah [ __ ] don't tell me I
just saved in the forest of times I did
[ __ ] me okay
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you let me run
there's only one on that side but
probably doesn't matter and I'm out okay
maybe my best bet will be hiding in that
corner because he doesn't seem to be
able to hit me very much
[ __ ] are they just in Duvall nerble up
there [ __ ] hell
man one to the other doesn't matters
yeah don't matter
oh I made it oh ha oh what's that noise
wha
oh no oh no there's a number uninsured
this 45 what it was like whoa I killed
people no wonder I'm a psychopath that
makes sense
that was it oh my god that was the last
level holy crap no wonder was so tough
oh wow cool how's this holy crap
I like this sequence anyway wow I didn't
expect it to end now but man oh man
these guys these guys know how to scare
I mean a lot of its jump scares but
still the atmosphere of being able to
put all pull off that atmosphere in this
game in half-life 1 especially without
the modifications that they made in that
in the cry fear
impeccable incredible well well done I
applaud your efforts and it's it's just
incredible what you were able to do I'm
speaking to this maker somewhat of
course but yeah like crap that's scared
to crap out of me alright Wow Andrea's
rønneberg did an amazing work
look at all this stuff you did man some
of the some of the modders in the world
are some of the most talented game
makers around like they just seriously
they have like the best some of the best
ideas in the will and the drive to
complete a project I can totally respect
and understand these guys are absolutely
incredible for doing this and I applaud
their efforts they're just I I applaud
anyone that goes out of their way
tries to give up stuff to make their
dream come true and make something come
to life and to get out a free mod like
this with as much work that was put into
it is incredible I mean I'm just taken
aback by this and cry fear to know that
they did both of these I mean there was
a big gap in between them but still no
matter what this it's a very very good
job like outstanding everyone should try
this mod I mean it's sad to know that as
years go by things like these like the
old mods are gonna just die out and they
still have so much value to them like
that
that was incredible because it's just
scared crap out of me
but anyway ending one pub for ah try
taking different routes sometimes the
route is right ah interesting
so I did I had a feeling I had a feeling
that was happening because I sometimes
if I'm just running away from Oscars I
would just go in a certain direction and
I wouldn't think that it would be the
right way but apparently you know it was
because it just bought me over to it but
anyway that's all I'm gonna Robin
rambling a bit so I'm gonna close it up
here anyway thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed this let's
play I certainly did and anything this
guy comes out with I will play again
because very very well done and I may do
another episode trying to find the
secrets or not I don't know other people
have probably done it better than I can
ever do you know finding the secrets but
anyway thank you guys again for watching
and look forward to more amnesia because
some stories as I'm doing the Skyrim
lips play witch
if you're watching this from the future
I was doing a Skyrim let's play at the
same time because I wanted to like stick
my foot in both pools one horror one non
horror good games you know but anyway I
look forward to more amnesia custom
stories and counting down the days to
amnesia a machine for pigs so thanks
again everybody for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye